مشاهدينا الكرم من مقاطع الفيديو التي
شاهدناها على الشاشه اخذناها بعض الصور
ومن خلال الفيديو والصوره التي نشاهدها
على الشاشه الان يمكننا الوصول الى المكان
المستهدف هذه اللقطه اخذناها من مقطع
الفيديو المنشور قبل قليل والذي شاهدناه
واستطعنا الوصول التقريبا الى المكان
المستهدف نحن نتحدث بشكل اساسي عن اصفهان
وعندما نتحدث عن اصفهان فنحن نتحدث عن 350
كلم جنوبيه العاصمه طهران والذي يريد ان
يتحرك من طهران الى اصفهان وبالعكس او من
اصفهان الى طهران او الى مدينه قممه يجب
عليه السلوك الطريق الامام الخميني
السريعه هذا الطريق الذي يخرج
المركاب من مدينه اصفهان ويتحركون به الى
مدينه طهران العاصمه على هذا الطريق هناك
تقاطع مهم هو تقاطع منه هذا هو التقاطع
على الطريق
امام الخميني السريع الذي اشرنا اليه قبل
قليل عند هذا التقاطع وقع الانفجار مسيرات
استهدفت كما ذكرت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
ثلاث مسيرات استهدفت هذه المنطقه
التحليليه يقول بان الاماكن المستهدفه اما
هو هذا المكان الذي نتحدث عنه هو الذي
تحدثت عنه وسائل اعلام ايرانيه وامريكيه
او انه هذا المكان الذي يتبع لي وزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه وفقا المعلومات التي
حصلنا عليها وتحليل الصور ومقاطع الفيديو
التي تم بثها والتي اشهرنا اليها قبل قليل
اذا نتحدث عن هذين وقد يكون المكان هو
مكان واحد همم بمعنى ان تابعيني في وزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه وبالتالي المستهدف وهذا
المكان وهذا المكان وفقه ما همم تم نشره
من معلومات وبيانات رسميه ثلاث مسيرات كما
قالت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه البحث بالبحث
طبعا كما اشرنا هذا المكان يقع بالقرب من
وحده اصفهان التابعه لمركز ابحاث الفضاء
الايراني الخاضع هذا المركز طبيعه الحالي
عقوبات امريكيه وهو مسؤول عن البرنامج او
برنامج الصواريخ الايرانيه البرسيل طبعا
لا تذكر اصفهان الا وتذكر معها المفاعلات
النوويه الايرانيه بشكل اساسي يتحدث عن
منشات نتانز النوويه الايرانيه التي
استهدفت بعده مرات بالضربات داخليه
وخارجيه وكذلك ايضا تعتبر منشات اصفهان
للصناعات النوويه المعروفه باسم يو سي احد
ابرز المعالم الامويه في المقاطعه تانز
طبعا بطبيعه الحال هي المكان المهم الذي
اشرنا اليه وهو برنامج التخصيب هو القلب
برنامج تخصيب الايراني تتهم ايران اسرائيل
بتخريبه عام 2000 او واحد و20 ونادرا
طبيعه الحال ما يقرر المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون بعمليات التي تنفذها الوحدات
العسكريه
اسرائيل او وكاله المخابرات اتابع لهيه
تشرين ثاني الماضي قبل عده شهور من الان
بث التلفزيون الرسمي الايراني مقطع فيديو
لمن قال انهم اعضاء او اعترافات في اعضاء
حزب كملاء الكردي المعارض وانهم خططوا
لاستهداف من شارع العسكريه عندما نتحدث عن
هذه الجزئيه هذه طبعا ذكرنا الروايه
الايرانيه بان المسيرات قد تكون جاءت من
الداخل ولكن هناك وحديث وسرير عن ان
اسرائيل هي التي شاركت في هذه العمليه
ولكن هذا يطرح تساؤلات عن اين جاءت هذه
المسيرات هناك عده خيارات اما انها جاءت
من اسرائيل وقطعت كل هذه المسافه وضربت
اصفهان بطبيعه الحال بوفقه والروايه فان
اسرائيل هي المسؤوله ولكن هل من الممكن ان
تكون سيارات قطعت كل هذه المسافه هنا يلفت
النظر الى انه في الثالث عشر من مارس
الماضي اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني من
سوريا عن هجوم ضرب
ضرب في محافظه اربيل شماليه العراق ضرب ما
وصفه الحرس الثوري الايراني بالمقر
الاستراتيجي للمؤامرات والمخططات
الصهيونيه العدائيه بصواريخ دقيقه قال
الحرس الثوري الايراني بانه ضرب في هذه
النقطه مركزا للمساد الاسرائيلي وهنا يمكن
الرابط بين ما ذكره التلفزيون ايراني فيه
نوفمبر الماضي عن الخليه او الاعضاء
التابعين الحزب الكرديس الكردي المعارض
هذه ابرز الخيارات او صح التعبير
الاحتمالات التي من الممكن ان تكون تم
استهداف اصفهان بالثلاث مسيرات اما انها
من الداخل او من العراق او من اسرائيل